Un asistent produce un răspuns convingător. Dar nu vedem clar ce surse a folosit sau cum a ajuns la concluzie.
Într-un proces important, calitatea textului nu rezolvă singură problema controlului. Trebuie să putem pune întrebări despre muncă.
Cum transformăm un rezultat greu de inspectat într-un proces pe care oamenii îl pot urmări și corecta?
În loc să cerem doar un răspuns final, descriem pași: alegerea surselor, extragerea afirmațiilor și verificarea lor.
Fiecare rezultat păstrează o legătură cu intrările sale. Putem vedea unde a apărut o afirmație și ce o susține.
O urmă explicită face procesul mai inspectabil. Nu dovedește, prin simpla ei existență, că fiecare pas a fost corect.
Într-o analiză, asistentul formulează o afirmație. Lângă ea păstrează pasajul pe care se bazează.
Un cititor poate verifica dacă acel pasaj spune într-adevăr ceea ce pretinde analiza. Poate observa o omisiune sau o interpretare prea puternică.
Legătura nu certifică adevărul sursei. Face doar posibilă o verificare care altfel ar fi mult mai dificilă.
Înainte de publicare, un om poate aproba, poate cere o corecție sau poate opri procesul.
Un buton de aprobare nu este suficient. Alegerea trebuie să producă o schimbare observabilă în ceea ce se întâmplă mai departe.
Un sistem controlabil face vizibile aceste puncte de decizie și păstrează contextul în care persoana a intervenit.
Un proces bine documentat poate conține în continuare surse greșite, evaluări slabe sau aprobări superficiale.
Avem nevoie de teste care introduc erori și verifică dacă ele sunt detectate, explicate și corectate la timp.
Schema de aici ilustrează un principiu de proiectare. Nu este un rezultat experimental și nu promite eliminarea erorilor.
Ideea este să tratăm munca AI ca pe un proces inspectabil, nu ca pe o succesiune de răspunsuri izolate.
De unde vine afirmația? Ce s-a schimbat pe parcurs? Unde poate interveni un om?
Valoarea practică apare atunci când răspunsurile la aceste întrebări pot fi testate în sarcini concrete, nu doar desenate într-o arhitectură.